hi it's matthew martin from details and
i just saw adam kimmel's collection and
i was loving the slimmer fit this season
it's a lot similar than it usually is
but you could tell that it still retain
the comfort and the masculinity that
he's really known for
the inspiration this season was cia and
air force special operations but i love
the fact that he took that idea and made
it more wearable and modern and updated
especially with a lot of the fabrics
the suits had all really trim peak
lapels which i really liked my favorite
suit in the collection was this
beautiful blue double breasted suit that
was a really elegantly tailored piece
for him but also looked really
comfortable
he paired a lot of the suiting and the
more tailored pieces with these work
boots and also a utility shoe it was a
great juxtaposition of a tailored item
with a more rugged shoe
was a great suede shearling bomber that
was really cool it was a really nice
update on a classic military piece
also i loved this hooded nylon jacket
that these patch pockets and around the
patch pockets he had all this beautiful
light blue top stitching which really
made the pocket stand out and took a
more classic utility piece and made it
look a lot more modern and chic
his collection is really versatile which
i love because you can really mix and
match all the pieces and easily
incorporate it into clothes you already
have follow me on twitter at detailsmat
and check out details.com for more
videos from paris